what lies west of the sunset sea what
secrets does the empire of yeti hold in
the east could we hear more about jon
snow in the north there's no chance
these game of thrones spin-offs could go
south
in episode 1 of house of the dragon
allison's hightower studies the history
of princess nymeria with her companion
princess rhaenyra targaryen nymeria is
considered such an incredible character
arya stark named her direwolf after her
in the original game of thrones series
and hbo is already developing a series
about her called ten thousand ships
she took lord moore's martel of dawn to
husband and burned her own fleet of
sunspear to show her people that they
were finished running
the legend of princess nymeria begins
about a thousand years prior to the
events in game of thrones prince garin
thought her people known as the reiner
could hold their own against the dragon
riding valyrians nymeria suspected he
was wrong and when most of the men died
fighting or were taken into slavery she
fled essos with mostly women and
children on the ten thousand ships they
had left after a few extended stopovers
nymeria and the rhoynar settled in dawn
where she burned her enormous but barely
seaworthy fleet to make the point that
they'd found their new home at the time
the dornish were having their own game
of thrones and niberia married her
preferred candidate for the crown
moore's martel she became the warrior
queen uniting the kingdom and ushering
in dawn's culture of independence and
gender parity it can be argued that a
series about nymeria would let audiences
see one of george r.r martin's greatest
heroines in a more nuanced light since
she lived so long ago and what we know
of her borders are myth ten thousand
ships could be an ideal vehicle for even
more spectacle action and romance than
thrones fans are used to for example
besides that unimaginably huge fleet the
rhino were defeated with an airborne
assault of 300 dragons
some storytelling formulas are tried and
true such as the trope of the reluctant
adult forced to care for the precocious
kid currently you can argue that the
biggest guardian child duo is the
mandalorian and grogu while a game of
thrones has its own decidedly darker
version with arya and the hound but
george r.r martin's novelis collected as
a knight of the seven kingdoms happened
to contain an even better one and it
just so happens that a series based on
the tales of dunk and egg is reportedly
a high priority for hbo dunk is sir
duncan the tall a poor squire from flea
bottom who pulls himself up by his own
bootstraps and white lies to become a
great knight egg is an upperclass boy in
disguise who becomes a squire and
travelling companion their adventures
are episodic and genuinely more
lighthearted than the other yarns martin
spins but this did an adequate amount of
chivalry backstabbing warmongering
seafaring and sexual tension to please
the average throne's viewer a duncan egg
series would also give audiences the
chance to see characters in their youth
that they've already met a night of the
seven kingdoms begins roughly 90 years
prior to game of thrones and frequently
ties back into existing law for instance
beloved character sir brienne of taft is
related to sir duncan the tour though
martin has not yet revealed exactly how
but the season 8 episode in which she's
knighted is not so subtly titled a
knight of the seven kingdoms
the most consequential event in george
r.r martin's entire body of work could
be aegon targaryen's conquest of
westeros aegon is such a pivotal
character the game of thrones timeline
revolves around him dates are recorded
as bc for before conquest and ac for
after conquest as entertaining as it is
to watch his family line fight each
other for the crown 100 years later in
house of the dragon or fight for their
very survival centuries later in game of
thrones we'd really like to see the
military campaign that started it all
aegon targaryen the first is probably
the most cinematic personality martin
has yet invented this striking hulking
blonde-haired purple-eyed man began his
endeavor to unite the seven kingdoms
when as we find out in the house of the
dragon he had a vision about a threat
from the north
egon foresaw the end of the world of men
uh just to begin with a terrible winter
together with his sister wives assenier
and rhaenys yes he married both of his
sisters and their dragons balerion
maraxis and vega aegon managed to
incorporate six of westeros's seven
kingdoms into his domain
some willingly bent the knee while
others had to be convinced though
ultimately he was never able to subdue
the dornish though he looms large in the
game of thrones universe aegon was a
complicated person there's enough
material just in his tenuous
relationship with the faith of the seven
to make for a compelling tv series let
alone his wives his two very different
sons the six kingdoms he ruled over and
the many battles which won him control
alas there's no egg on the conqueror
show currently in the works arya stark
played by the perfectly cast maisie
williams was one of the breakout
characters of game of thrones and one of
the easiest to root for when we leave
her at the end of season 8 she informs
her siblings that she's not going back
to winterfell
what's west of westeros
i don't know
in martin's novels what's west of
westeros is the sunset sea a body of
water that is believed to be too vast to
cross so little has been written about
what lies beyond the shores of the
westerlands that the showrunners or even
martin himself could have a blast
dreaming up a new world for arya and to
shipmates to discover
exactly what that world would look like
like arya's voyage itself could go in
several different directions some
characters hold that there are dangerous
creatures such as krakens or sea dragons
in the sunset sea if hbo wanted to lean
into magical realism the way it is done
with dragons white walkers the lord of
light and the faceless men in game of
thrones and arya goes west series would
certainly allow creatives to get
fantastical an explorer narrative could
also riff on themes related to europe's
colonization of north and south america
but the main reason to make an aria show
is simple more arya from her time as
tywin lannister's cabera to her
world-saving dagger wielding lunge at
the night king arya was consistently at
the center of some of the series most
iconic scenes unfortunately as of now
there's no arya on the horizon
in house of the dragon cordless valarion
has several important posts he's the
husband of reigns targaryen the one time
heir who was passed over with viserys's
branch of the family tree he's the
master of ships charged with outfitting
and commanding the royal fleet he's also
master of the formidable driftmark
stronghold acts of the moderating voice
on king viserys's small council and is
the richest man in the world corliss
will get up to his fair share of
plotting and battling in house of the
dragon but decades before that he
accumulated power and fortune as a young
man with unmatched talent on the high
seas and in trade caller says origin
story will either be called the sea
snake a nickname that comes from the
name of a ship he designed and built or
nine voyages which were the number of
journeys he took to fire off places like
pentos volantis and the golden empire of
yiti regardless of its title it'll
illustrate the far-reaching adventures
of this charismatic character before he
was a fixture of king viserys's court in
the novel fire and blood corliss is
described as wise in peace valiant in
war and someone who clings to life like
a drowning sailor clinging to the
wreckage of a sunken ship though steve
toussaint shines like sunlight on water
as coalescent house of the dragon a
young actor would probably have to
portray him in the spin-off while the
proposed 10 000 ship series focuses on a
one-way journey the sea snake would have
a completely different flavor as an
island-hopping treasure-collecting romp
one of the places younger cordless
visits is yiti a thriving empire in the
far east
a sea snake managed to bring back silks
and spices from the golden empire making
him twice as rich as he'd been before
drora mormont also asked daenerys to run
away with him to yiti after carl drogo's
death in game of thrones but outside of
these few connections yiti has a rich
culture and a dramatic history all its
own one worthy of its own tv show hbo is
in pre-production on an animated series
that will aim to tell the stories of the
golden empire though no release date has
been announced and no other relevant
information has been revealed while it'd
be great to give asian actors an
opportunity to play live action roles
within the game of thrones universe the
colorful and diverse world of yiti which
boasts lush farmland basilisk ridden
jungles and bustling urban centers can
be beautifully rendered in animation
with a history that stretches back
thousands of years occasionally
intersecting with valyria and its
dragons there's just as much drama
between the various god emperors who
aspire to the yeti throne as any other
royal family in game of thrones a show
that delves into yeti a subject which
george r.r martin has written
comparatively little about could make
for a refreshing change of scenery
as game of thrones drew to a close hbo
began mining martin's novels for more
content the network reportedly met with
potential writers to develop pitches and
assured them that no concepts were too
weird in total about 15 spin-off ideas
were considered
one of the pitches that failed to get
the green light was a superhero team-up
story about westerosi gods while that
may sound a bit too much like eternals
marvel's foreign ancient religions a
series that further explores the role of
religion in the seven kingdoms could be
interesting does that star they keep the
old gods
no my lord
i was named in the light of the seven
characters in game of thrones often
referred to their deities as the old
gods and the new the new refers to the
seven also known as the seven gods and
the seven faced god who became the
deities of the most widely practiced
faith in westeros followers pray to the
father the mother the maiden the crone
the warrior the smith and the stranger
each representing a different aspect of
humanity for example a soldier might
pray to the warrior for bravery before
an upcoming battle this septad may or
may not have been real people but their
origins are from about 6 000 years
before the high sparrow wreaks havoc in
season 5. as in life religious factions
vie for political power in westeros with
just as much fervor as any of the noble
families
a show about the seven that flashed back
and forth between the faith's foundings
and its influence circa the original
game of thrones timeline would likely be
as dark mysterious and morally ambiguous
as the rest of martin's world
house of the dragon is filling in the
juicy backstory of one of westeros's
most notorious families and so far
audiences are happy to have all the
salacious details it stands to reason
they'll be just as curious to know more
about the other family at the center of
game of thrones and hbo may have planned
to revisit the kingdom of the north with
a series called either blood moon or the
long knight starring british actress
naomi watts it was to take place in the
age of heroes thousands of years ago
they even spent 30 million dollars on a
pilot before unceremoniously canning the
project though legions of thrones fans
would surely love to see the unaided
episode from context clues it sounds
like it may have shifted its focus away
from familiar faces and places perhaps
the series that sat squarely on the
shoulders of king brandon stark the
founder of winterfell and house stark
would have fed better parts of the fun
of a brand that builders story is that
the man himself may never have existed
though there are myriad carvings
depicting his great works and his body
supposedly lies in winterfell's crypt
according to the companion book the
world of ice and fire bran's legend may
be the result of a millennia of
exaggeration and conflation generations
of starks have been named after him
eventually culminating with king bran
the broken at the end of game of thrones
we've seen the seven kingdoms in chaos
and decline and now we've seen them at
one of their high points in house of the
dragon it'd be fun to see them in the
distant past as one of the franchise's
most familiar locales was in the process
of being constructed
when game of thrones ended in 2019 most
fans assumed that they were leaving
behind the likes of jon snow and sansa
stark for good the news of spin-offs was
already in the air and all of them were
pre-chores that seemed to make sense as
george r.r martin has yet to complete
his novel series and throne stars like
kit harrington were already moving on to
other projects so it took a moment for
the idea to register when hbo announced
that it intended to make a true sequel
about jon snow's life after the deaths
of the night king and daenerys targaryen
with harrington reprising the role that
made him a household name
i don't expect we'll ever see each other
again
i wouldn't be so sure
unlike the rest of the shows in
development there's no source material
upon which to base a jon snow sequel
series all the potential writers have to
go on is that john exiled himself to the
north after killing his arms and form a
flame to prevent further atrocities we
can assume he's been living as a
wildling again maybe as their chosen
leader but even that is an open question
this much of a blank slate could be a
good thing or a bad thing but what's
promising is that it could be a chance
for viewers to catch up with their
favorite thrones characters one could
easily imagine sansa arya samuel thali
and even brienne popping up through
cameos now and then even more
tantalizing it could elevate christopher
hifu's character tormund giantsbane to
co-star
[Music]